[Music]
hey friends what up Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of boy spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain uh today I wanted to
take you through some stuff that on the
surface of it seems pretty simple but
that I actually think is more
complicated than we give it credit for
which is
just moving around and together same
with our two hands whether this be
anti-spin or whether it be an extensions
in spin Etc
um I think finding the ways of getting
through this is actually a deceptively
difficult process and I'd like to take
you through it but first before we do
that I do want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinski and
Becca beckonen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission cool so this actually came up
very recently in my live stream classes
I've been teaching timing and direction
to my students and I really realized
that like timing and Direction really is
something that is not nearly as
intuitive as we think it is for uh
moving our bodies around so I kind of
wanted to start with uh together same
because I think it's deceptively hard
for people to wrap their heads around
what's going on here but more
specifically there are some things we
can do with our body mechanics that make
this so much easier for us now in most
cases when people perform together same
for the first time I'm willing to bet
that they're just moving their hands
around in circles directly in front of
them like so and you'll notice that as
I'm doing this I'm keeping my shoulders
Square to the camera yeah
really what's happening here is that my
shoulders are basically responsible for
all the movement here so I'm reaching
across up out and back down across up
out and back down as I'm moving my hands
around and together same
now you'll notice as I'm doing this when
I move over to either side there's a
pretty large gap between my hands here
and you know sometimes this is actually
kind of useful you know if say you want
to do something like switching into an
anti-brid when you get to either side
you kind of already have a leg up on
changing the alignment of the POI in
your hands but very frequently that's
not the intention there at all
so do we have a different option here
well yes as it turns out we do now I
want you to take a quick look at how I
perform together same versus the way I
just demonstrated it for you where this
is how I demonstrated it originally
and this is how I usually do together
same there's a very very subtle
difference now granted there's still
that little bit of gap between my hands
as I'm going around but it's a much
smaller Gap than if I were doing it this
way why is that
if I keep my shoulders Square to the
camera it means that I'm when I'm
reaching to either side there has to be
at least a shoulder's width difference
between the positions of my hands
because after all one of my arms is not
significantly longer than the other one
so you see at least the shoulders width
difference between the position of the
two hands on either side of your body
how can we fix this well by shortening
up the distance between our shoulders on
either side by turning our upper bodies
into either side so if instead I think
of this as being I'm twisting my other
my upper body back and forth as I'm
going around then all of a sudden I have
access to this alignment right here
where my hands are much closer together
but I still have those middle positions
there where my shoulders are square to
the camera it's hard to tell them doing
this because I've gotten pretty good at
just isolating my head on top of it so
you know as I'm performing this it
doesn't look like I'm doing that's
anything that much significantly
different from when I'm doing this right
it's only a difference of if I'm moving
my upper body with my hands going around
and to be perfectly Frank with you I
think that this is actually better for
your shoulders too let me show you why
um as you're like reaching back and
forth like this you're engaging a lot of
like your pectoral muscles that you're
you're creating a really really closed
space here whenever you're reaching
across your body whereas when you're
turning your shoulders with it
essentially all you're doing is you're
keeping your arms square with your
shoulders the entire way going around
you just happen to be changing which
direction your shoulders are square to
as you're doing so
so the easy way to practice this is
honestly just to start with your hands
at your hips bring them up next to your
ears and back down and you'll notice as
I'm doing this I'm putting a lot of
effort into making sure that I'm not
shrugging my shoulders as my arms go up
um
this is one of those things that can
lead to injuries and it's not good for
you and also it just doesn't create as
pleasing a line like if I'm shrugging my
shoulders to reach my arms up versus if
I let my shoulders relax and just take
my natural range of motion here you
notice how it opens up a lot of negative
space between my ears and my arms that
is something that I personally think is
a much more pleasing line
that can be done here
so practice sweeping your arms up and
sweeping your arms down your hands
should always be in front of you never a
moment when they should go behind your
head like that like it should you should
never have a moment where you're
reaching back behind your shoulders
because that's how you get them injured
um
instead keep your hands in front of you
as you move your hands up and down up
and down yeah so step two of this I'm
going to turn my entire body well not my
entire body but my upper body over to my
left here and I'm going to start with my
hands at my hips and sweep them all the
way up towards my ears I'm not going to
turn my entire upper body over to the
right and drop them back down or I guess
sweep them back down towards my hips
turn my upper body to the left
swing my arms up near my ears
turn all the way over to the right swing
them all the way down next to my hips
again to the left swing them up to your
ears
to the right swing them down to your
hips and as
you practice this work to make that turn
to either side happen seamlessly and
quickly yeah like if you'll notice
there's never a point where I'm not
moving my shoulders into either position
here and then you know the the kind of
icing to stick on the top of the cake
then is just keeping my head isolated
looking towards the camera as my
shoulders are moving back and forth and
creating this beautiful line one of the
reasons that this is really great is
that when it comes time to do things
like flowers especially inspin and
anti-spin flowers it's really helpful to
have this in between space where the POI
can reach between your arms if you
flatten them up against your body like
this it gets way harder to make the
alignment work whereas if I'm shifting
my shoulders here I've created this kind
of buzzsaw plain place where I can stick
one of the POI as I'm moving around here
and then just as I go from side to side
I'm switching which hand is stuck in
that buzz saw plane and that is part of
how I maintain that line going around
and I also maintain enough clearance for
the POI to be able to move past each
other without hitting each other yeah
I will show you that from the side here
basically what I'm looking to do as I'm
moving my upper body around trying not
to hit the things that I have mounted to
the ceiling
is that I can then
use that space
between my arms to shift the POI back
and forth in front of me and in theory
then I can create really beautiful
flowers that move my hands around such a
fashion that they are staying as close
together as they possibly can on either
side of me while also creating that
lovely little space in between them that
I can use for my flowers whether they be
anti-spinner in spin as I'm going around
and it all comes down to just sweeping
your arms up and down as your upper body
moves around and again I swear this is
better for your shoulders in the long
run and it creates a prettier alignment
too you you create much much better
lines this way
so yeah that's how I would recommend
that you play around in together same as
you're working on your flowers yes
um cool so
um
if you'd like to get on board with those
live stream classes that I am teaching
you can do so by heading on over to
crowdcast.io slash directs Factor POI we
are currently in the middle of uh doing
my third of what are likely to be nine
units so uh please come join us all of
the lessons are recorded so you can jump
in whenever you would like to and catch
up with everybody who's already on board
yeah awesome and of course if you dug
this video please make sure to like
share comment and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow yeah
foreign
[Music]
would not be possible if it were not for
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you all so very much for
your support for me and my mission and
if y'all out there watching right now
are interested in signing up to support
my work but are not currently supporters
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up you can do that at the link either
down in the description or the card that
just popped up if you're watching this
video on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you will be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world and helping people connect
with their brains and their bodies as
creative people so go check that out
please and thank you now if you'd like
to check out more tutorials in this
series or I guess these are really
lessons I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching this video on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you're probably going to like this top
video here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a shot as well
thank you all so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow this week and
I'll see you with another video real
soon
peace